hello and welcome to the candles side in
spanish of health to natalia badly had
this week we start a new
month with the latest in the world of
entertainment here in las vegas and the
celebration of the holidays festivities patrias
maluma and his tour for pigua  I arrived at
another ruin inside
mandalay bay this saturday and thus kicking
off the concerts for the month of
september there are still tickets available
for the concert you can get it
via ticketmaster.com
well today talking about
the independence day celebrations  of mexico and the
celebrations of hispanic heritage month
the city of north las vegas already
has its plans in place for this
important date you are invited to celebrate the
shout on wednesday september 15 in
the report book starting at 5 in the
afternoon  this event is completely
free and will have a little bit of everything for
everyone we continue with the celebrations of
the national holidays this time with a bit
of metal attitude it was on Friday
september 10 you will be able to leave the scream in the
center of las vegas on the mainland with
a unique concert by listening
to metal h a mariachi band with
a gm function so you are celebrating
while we rock amos the weekend the
festivities begin at  8 at night and it
's completely free I went out present
so see you there
good by the way if you want a
complete list of all the Hispanic artists
coming to Las Vegas this month to
celebrate these national holidays visit
an out dotcom good if you're a fan
of soccer here I share some of
the events happening in the james
state jan yunís will face eastern
in washington on september 2 and then
on september 4 the
inaugural game of biguá and arizona will take place and
finally on monday september 13 the
las vegas' riders will have their
season opener against baltimore
we are now talking about entertainment on the
strip and that is the sedesol
light residence  virus cloud is back on
stage his return comes just in time for
his 15th anniversary celebration
in las vegas the shows take place thursday
through sunday at the mirage resort in el with
ticket prices starting at $79
and bruno mars fans get
ready  guys because the singer
just added two dates for his
residence in the park well with two
shows confirmed on October 1st and 2nd
tickets and they are on sale at
ticketmaster dotcom
and the magic show that
welcomes teachers and educators with
a special offer during the month of
September you can receive up to 4
free tickets for your presentation at
the flamingo resort you have until September 30
to take advantage of this
offer which by the way you must reserve
48 hours or 2 days in advance
visit the dotcom industry  For more
information,
do not forget the dotcom industry again,
there you will find all the
information that I am giving you about all
these e  vents and more until las
vegas arrived' nothing in spanish greets you natalia
marceñido see you next week
[Music]